c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public qui tourne au cœur de cette
question jusqu'où ira la vague
nationaliste en Europe après la Pologne
la Hongrie ou encore l'Italie la
Slovaquie vient de placer en tête des
législatives Robert fitzo un populiste
pro-rus qui s'oppose à l'aide militaire
en Ukraine avant de débattre sur les
conséquences de ce nouvel équilibre sur
l'issue de la guerre Audrey betas nous
présente cet homme politique qui a déjà
été Premier ministre et qui avait du
démissionner c'était en 2018 après
l'assassinat d'un journaliste
d'investigation
ce ne sont que quelques mots prononcés
par Robert fitso après la victoire de
son parti aux élections législatives
slovaque quelques mots qui résument
l'ensemble de sa campagne la Slovaquie
et ses habitants ont des problèmes plus
importants à régler que du crâne c'est
tout ce que j'ai à dire pour l'instant
il doit maintenant former une coalition
mais le profil de Robert de fisso
inquiète en Europe et en Ukraine ex
Premier ministre social-démocrate évincé
du pouvoir sur fond de corruption il a
fait cette fois-ci campagne sur des
thématiques d'extrême droite pro Poutine
et populiste l'Allier de Victor Orban
pourrait briser l'unité européenne sur
le soutien à l'Ukraine notamment car
Robert fitso a prévenu la Slovaquie ne
livrera pas d'armes supplémentaires à
son voisin pour l'Union
européennement alors très relatifs à
l'échelle des 27 néanmoins il y a un
renforcement ce qu'on pourrait qualifier
des forces politiques et libérales
de cette mouvance
jusqu'ici est incarné essentiellement
par les gouvernements de Hongrie et de
Pologne et cela pourrait ne pas
s'arrêter là en Pologne justement dans
deux semaines des élections doivent
déterminer si la droite nationaliste et
ultra conservatrice reste au pouvoir
depuis 8 ans elle est en conflit
régulier avec l'Union européenne qui la
plusieurs fois sanctionné pour ses
entravaves indépendance de la justice et
au droit des personnes LGBT plus une
nouvelle victoire du pis conforterait
cette politique alors l'opposition se
mobilise ici plus d'un million de
personnes réunies dans les rues de
Varsovie dans la foule des drapeaux
européens nous sommes tout proche de ne
plus recevoir de fonds européens de
couper les contacts avec l'Europe et
cela limite le développement de notre
jeunesse et de tout le pays le
renforcement des gouvernements et
libéraux en Pologne en Slovaquie en
Hongrie pourrait aussi mettre en
porte-à-faux les ambitions écologiques
de l'Europe auxquels ces pays s'opposent
régulièrement
tout de suite notre second débat avec
Sylvain Kahn bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur au Centre d'histoire de
Sciences power de ce livre Histoire de
la construction de l'Europe depuis 1945
et publié aux éditions presse
universitaires de France bienvenue à
vous Christine Dubois Clément bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes chercheuse associés
à chère risk à l'Institut
d'Administration des Entreprises Paris
un Panthéon Sorbonne et chercheuse au
centre de recherche de l'école des
officiers de la Gendarmerie nationale
bienvenue à vous Richard Verdi bonsoir
et bonsoir vous êtes correspondants
français Europe pour le média Suisse
Blic et Guillaume Daret est resté à mes
côtés
ça m'aurait manqué
on va commencer peut-être par rappeler
que Robert alors soit comprenant ce fut
le dire comme ça Robert fitchau il doit
former une coalition sa politique elle
va évidemment dépendre de cette
coalition à quel point quand même il est
opposé aux livraison d'armes à l'Ukraine
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de ça pour
commencer
on peut dire de ça c'est que il a il a
dit durant sa campagne pas forcément
qu'il était opposé sur le principe mais
qu'il fallait d'abord s'occuper des
Slovaques et de ses compatriotes
et par ailleurs c'est un peu un revenant
oui c'est vraiment un revenant parce que
on croyait qu'il était mort
politiquement politiquement et il y
avait une raison enfin je sais pas si
elle est bonne ou mauvaise mais enfin il
y avait une raison très très importante
à cette mort politique c'est qu'il était
quand même il a démissionné lorsqu'il
était Premier ministre en 2018 si je me
souviens bien parce qu'il était
soupçonné d'avoir quand même été trempé
dans le meurtre de deux journalistes qui
étaient en train de sortir un article
manifestement très important sur la
collusion qui pouvait exister entre
certaines sphères gouvernementales et la
mafia une et quatre Machia italienne la
calabraise je crois bon donc
on pensait que ça avait tué
politiquement il a déjà été premier
ministre trois fois si je ne m'abuse
et donc il a viré progressivement besoin
il est un peu comparable à Orban en
Hongrie de plus en plus populiste même
si son parti le smmer SD est toujours
membre de du groupe parlementaire au
Parlement européen
des socialistes et des démocrates voilà
bon donc tout ça pour dire que les gens
qui connaissent très bien la vie
politique slovaque considère que
il y a ce qu'il a dit en campagne
évidemment
c'est il va pas faire le contraire de ce
qu'il a dit mais en fonction de la
coalition qui va réussir à mettre sur
pied il n'a entre guillemets que 23% des
voix absolument pas gouverner seul il
mettra plus ou moins de l'eau dans son
vin et son vin sera-t-il rouge ou blanc
voilà mais donc oui en tous les cas il
est clair que
comparé au gouvernement sortant et
comparé à la présidente de Slovaquie qui
une autorité morale il est
[Musique]
c'est sa compagne qui a été tuée avec
lui a été pas vraiment journaliste
effectivement il y a eu deux morts et
deux factos comment dirais-je fitzo son
implication dans ce crime elle n'a pas
du tout il n'a pas du tout été blanchi
les soupçons demeurent que son entourage
et que des oligarques qui avec lequel il
était en contact ont commandité se
meurtre et le plus grave c'est que
l'oligarque en question celui que la
police avait
identifié comme étant le potentiel
responsable à lui était exonéré par la
justice la justice slovaque la relaxer
et elle n'a condamné qu'une femme qui
aurait prêté assistance à ce meurtre
donc le mal est profond Robert fitso est
quand même dans cette je ne sais pas si
on peut employer le mot pieuvre mais
dans le cas de la Slovaquie on peut
quand même la voir en tête et donc oui
il tient des rouages au sein de l'État
des rouages parallèles et il peut
au-delà de son score de 23%, je dirais
tirer un certain nombre de ficelles
particulièrement nauséabondes
personne ici ne peut dire si sa campagne
a été financée par une partie d'agent
austère donc on va pas aller sur ce
terrain mais peut-être sur un peu la
même question sur le terrain des des
valeurs entre un Poutine et un fixo
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de commun d'après
vous
pour autant que je l'ai compris fitzo et
encore une fois son parti le SMER SD qui
encore une fois fait partie de l'autre
groupe parlementaire de gauche c'est ça
qui m'a marqué quand
alors non mais je dis ça pour dire deux
choses c'est que à la fois on pourrait
se dire bon bah et donc est-ce qu'il va
être exclu un jour ou l'autre ou bien au
contraire est-ce que ça le tient ça veut
dire est-ce que du coup voilà il dit
certaines choses sur sa scène nationale
et au Parlement européen ou sur la scène
européenne notamment au Conseil européen
s'il revient chef de gouvernement il
peut en dire d'autres voilà bon
alors sur les valeurs sur les valeurs
ben oui il s'inscrit effectivement dans
on va dire un double courant je sais pas
si c'est un courant de pensée mais enfin
en tout cas une double doctrine on va
dire qui est présente un peu partout en
Europe en ce moment minoritaire à peu
près partout puis de temps en temps qui
est majoritaire ça arrive comme en ce
moment en Italie comment Hongrie depuis
2010 qui est que d'une part
on considère dans ce type de courant que
un certain nombre d'évolutions qu'on
appelle sociétal comme
pour résumer voilà le pluralisme
d'accord que ça soit dans le domaine de
l'orientation sexuelle dans le domaine
des origines culturelles dans le domaine
disons du brassage migratoire et des
flux de population mais également dans
le domaine de la vie politique le
pluralisme et regarder au minimum avec
méfiance et n'est pas considéré comme la
panacée donc ça veut dire que
concrètement les
personne LGBTQ on s'en méfie on n'est
pas sûr que ça soit bien pour l'ensemble
de la société
on pense que la liberté de la presse
c'est quand même ça peut être
problématique que l'indépendance de la
justice ça peut être problématique on
revient sur le droit à l'avortement
alors bon alors maintenant qu'est-ce que
très concrètement un gouvernement
fixo et encore une fois c'est pas sûr
j'ai commencé comme ça voilà qu'il
arrive à devenir Premier ministre
qu'est-ce que concrètement lui ferait
dans ces différents domaines c'est trop
tôt pour le dire s'il revient au pouvoir
mais en tout cas il s'inscrit c'est
comme ça qu'il a fait campagne sur voilà
le rejet ou la méfiance vis-à-vis du
pluralisme qui est censé caractériser
les démocraties libérales
dont qui sont censés être de telle façon
pour pouvoir entrer dans l'UE voilà
alors et si on a fait ce débat aussi
c'est parce qu'il y a cette dimension ou
cette menace je sais pas quel terme
employer qui pèse sur les livraisons des
armes à l'Ukraine on parlera aussi des
États-Unis dans un instant mais voilà
l'élection est l'hypothèse de l'arrivée
au pouvoir de Robert picso aura sans
doute des conséquences sur les
vraisemblaments en tout cas c'est ce que
nous dit ce politologue slova écoute
le leader politique du mouvement antivax
et anti masque dans ce pays pendant la
crise sanitaire aujourd'hui il est l'un
des hommes politiques les plus pros
russes qui utilisent le sentiment prorus
traditionnel d'une partie de notre
population
il promet beaucoup de choses entre
autres une revanche politique des purges
personnelles et une administration
d'État qui bloque de facto le mécanisme
de l'État de droit mais je pense que la
chose la plus sérieuse et sa promesse
d'arrêter les livraisons d'armes à
l'Ukraine
Christine Dubois Clément ça pourrait
avoir quelques conséquence je sais pas
si la Slovaquie est un pays qui donne
beaucoup plus d'armes à l'Ukraine mais
ce sentiment là d'une Union européenne
qui dans l'unanimisme se délite face à
cet enjeu alors il y a plusieurs choses
au-delà de l'aspect purement matériel de
la capacité de fournitures d'armes de la
Slovaquie à l'Ukraine vous avez un
symbole qui serait assez fort à partir
du moment où vous auriez un des États
membres qui prendrait une position qui
serait extrêmement différente d'arrêter
d'arrêter les livraisons d'armes alors
que depuis le début de l'invasion lancé
par la Russie à grande échelle donc en
février 2022 il y a eu une réaction
assez rapide et extrêmement unanime de
l'Union européenne donc si vous voulez
vous seriez dans un premier coin dans
cette dans cette unité qui a été
remarqué et remarquable d'ailleurs il
faut le dire c'est aussi pour ça que les
déclarations de la Pologne qui avaient
été sur ce point qui était revenu et là
aussi on est elles sont intervenues
rappelons-le juste avant un agenda
politique national donc on a d'autres
raisons qui sous-tendent beaucoup de
déclarations et bien vous risquez de
mettre un coin et là vous allez faire le
jeu d'une approche à leur initialement
qu'on appelait les 4D et qu'on appelle
maintenant les 5D ce qu'on a rajouté un
autre D qui est l'approche de la
propagande qui avait été théorisée
notamment par bennimo et qui vous
explique que vous allez tenter de
rejeter de distraire alors je vous donne
la traduction française
rejeter distraire découragé et diviser
notamment
sur sur les différents éléments qui sont
en opposition à votre approche et que ça
caractériserait assez fortement
l'approche de la Russie donc ce qui veut
dire que notamment vous allez rejeter
des éléments
qui ne sont pas à votre avantage alors
en allant donner par exemple du double
standard en allant noyé en allant etc
tout ce que vous allez faire donc ça
c'est pour le côté du rejet vous allez
déformer potentiellement un récit donc
ça c'est tout ce que vous allez avoir
sur des approches de fausses nouvelles
par exemple vous allez faire quand on
parle de distraction c'est un petit peu
l'effet du prestidigitateur qui se
pousse à main droite et qui pendant ce
temps là avec sa main gauche fait ce que
vous ne voyez pas donc vous allez mettre
un une projecteur par exemple sur un
événement vrai faux peu importe si vous
voulez histoire d'attirer l'attention un
petit peu pour les connaisseurs comme
l’œil de Sauron qui se tourne d'un côté
de l'autre côté vous pouvez faire ce que
vous voulez vous allez à partir de là
avoir de la fin du découragement donc si
vous voulez tout simplement dire
attention si vous prenez cette action
par exemple et bien les conséquences
seront extrêmement importantes voilà au
niveau de la dissuasion qui est un peu
une approche de la dissuasion nucaire
mais vous pouvez faire de manière
politique et enfin c'est la division
parce que le plus vous allez être en
capacité d'aller diviser le bloc qui
s'oppose à vos velléités quelle qu'elle
soit et bien le mieux vous vous porterez
puisque vous allez compliquer les prises
de décision et vous risquez d'avoir et
bien une force de frappe prenant l'image
en ayant la poche imagée qui sera
beaucoup moins puissante alors je
reprends 2D avec Charlie non mais c'est
passionnant ce que nous décrire
découragement et division parce que
c'est un peu ce à quoi on est en train
d'assister une sorte de de lassitude des
opinions publiques européen évidemment
c'est pas la même dans tous les pays
elle s'exprime différemment il y a pas
il y a pas d'échéance électorale aussi
importante partout mais c'est quand même
ce que ce à quoi on est en train
d'insister ouais d'abord je crois qu'il
faut avoir deux éléments en tête le
premier c'est que la lassitude elle
était attendue et d'une certaine manière
elle est normale quand vous avez une
guerre comme la guerre en Ukraine qui
dure depuis un an et demi que vous
approchez un deuxième hiver avec les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat bref il est
énorme qu'à un moment donné les
relations entre l'Ukraine et ses alliés
européens se tendent à fonctionner en
raison des échéances électorales et
d'ailleurs les Ukrainiens eux-même ne
sont pas surpris ils s'attendaient à ce
moment difficile on est dedans reste à
savoir comment on va sortir deuxième
chose qu'on n'a pas dit la Slovaquie est
frontalière de l'Ukraine donc il a
beaucoup de réfugiés il y a beaucoup de
réfugiés donc la solidarité slovaque a
quand même été à l'oeuvre et si l'on dit
que les Slovaques en ont marre des
déluqueraines il faut quand même prendre
en compte qu'ils l'ont beaucoup aidé
cette dernière année et demi alors moi
je crois pas du tout à la capacité de
fixo encore une fois s'il arrive au
pouvoir à diviser l'Europe puisque
lui-même n'a pas réussi Orban il faut
savoir qu'il a voté il a fini par voter
l'ensemble des sanctions européennes il
ne donne pas d'armes lui-même à
l'Ukraine mais l'Ukraine n'a jamais
demandé d'armes à la Hongrie et je
dirais il y a d'autres endroits et
d'autres types de matériels selon
l'Ukraine a besoin aujourd'hui ce sont
des matériels que d'autres manières ni
la Slovaquie ni la Hongrie ne pourrait
lui fournir ce que plus inquiétant chez
Robert fitso à mon avis ce sont quand
même je le répète c'est ramifications
mafieuses dont d'ailleurs le politologue
a parlé c'est-à-dire la possibilité de
le voir restaurer au sein de l'État
slovaque un certain nombre d'officines
et là ça pourrait poser des problèmes
parce que bien évidemment si l'État de
droit est attaqué en Slovaquie ça donne
un nouveau une fracture au sein de
l'Union européenne pas nécessairement
sur la question de soutien à l'Ukraine
mais sur d'autres sujets et ça c'est
compliqué à gérer mais pour l'instant je
dirais que c'est un peu une opposition
de basse intensité qui se prépare en
Slovaquie et n'oublions pas une dernière
chose qui est très importante c'est que
l'Ukraine a des moyens dans les torsions
sur la parce que l'Ukraine fournit
énormément de choses à la Slovaquie
notamment des céréales dont les
Slovaquie a besoin et donc il est pas
tellement sûr qu'elle veuille se fâcher
avec l'Ukraine c'est la grande
différence avec la Pologne qui elle a
des ressources agricoles suffisantes
c'est pas le cas de la Slovaquie mais on
reparlera de la Pologne tout à l'heure
mais je retiens deux éléments et je
démarre sur l'opinion publique
effectivement Sylvain Cannes
[Musique]
c'était prévisible que Robert fitso
puisse sortir en tête de ces élections
législatives parce qu'effectivement il y
a la lassitude face à l'accueil de
beaucoup de réfugiés Ukrainiens bon et
puis la situation économique que la
plupart des pays d'Europe connaissent
c'est pas vraiment une surprise
électorale à laquelle on vient
d'assister non alors c'est pas c'est pas
une surprise électorale d'abord parce
que depuis deux disons deux mois les
sondages le donnaient légèrement en tête
et au coude à coude avec le parti de la
présidente donc d'une certaine manière
voyez venir sa résurrection politique
bon et sur disons dans une plus longue
durée ou une moyenne durée
l'histoire politique de la Slovaquie
c'est deux ou trois dernières années
c'est vraiment caractérisé d'abord ça
c'est pas tout à fait récent par un très
grand mortcellement
il y a beaucoup de parties à 5% de
parties effectivement et puis on en
était à
4 gouvernements en deux ou trois ans
alors vous me direz si le cas de
l'Espagne donc c'est pas une
caractéristique de la Slovaquie
peut-être que on serait tous d'accord
ici pour constater que
sa caractérise un petit peu la vie
politique européenne et les vies
politiques européennes depuis une
quinzaine d'années que il y a beaucoup
beaucoup plus qu'avant d'incertitude les
électeurs disons changent davantage bon
donc de ce point de vue là Robert
fitchaud si j'ose dire c'est inscrit
dans une situation qui était très
volatile il a su en effet capitaliser
sur le mécontentement ou les inquiétudes
d'un certain nombre de ses compatriotes
mais on peut voir le verre à moitié
plein c'est à dire ayant décrit ainsi la
situation lui et son parti ne font que
23%. c'est pas 3035 ni 40%, il est pas
du tout dans la même situation
électorale de popularité que le pitch en
Pologne le parti qui est à peu près sur
le même type d'idéologie que lui mais
qui se casse à droite là il va y avoir
des élections en Pologne dans dans 15
jours le pitch était entre 35 et Droit
et Justice voilà donc le parti du
gouvernement sortant qui est là depuis
2015 qui est à la fois très nationaliste
très souverainiste très populiste en
Hongrie on a quand même Orban qu'on est
à 4 victoires électorales d'Oran avec le
fidèle avec discores qui sont entre 45
et 49 et demi pour cent mais est-ce que
pardon je vous intéresse parce que je
reprends le deuxième argument de Richard
vers lycée il y a quand même Orban était
un peu isolé là il les moins qu'est-ce
que ça va peser sur les raisons vous
avez raison mais je rejoins assez
Richard quand il dit que
Orban même Orban si j'ose dire elle lui
tout seul n'a pas réussi à infléchir la
politique européenne vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine et vis-à-vis de la Russie
et moi je serai assez surpris on peut se
tromper mais je serai assez surpris que
même s'ils sont deux c'est à dire Orban
et fit chaud dans l'hypothèse encore une
fois où il prend le pouvoir ça change
fondamentalement les choses
ils peuvent mettre un veto mais le reste
de l'Union européenne comme les
Etats-Unis parce que c'est quand même
deux pays qui sont dans l'OTAN comme
Richard le rappelait l'Ukraine en tous
les cas vis-à-vis de la stovaquie et
même une partie de la société civile
parce que il n'a que 23 % des voies même
s'il arrive à composer un gouvernement
ça veut dire que comme partout en Europe
il y a entre les sondages au baromètre
sont assez clair là-dessus il y a entre
5 ans et 80% de la population et en
Slovaquie c'est autour de 55 60% de gens
qui pensent qu'il faut continuer et
Fitcho lui-même pendant la campagne et
futur pendant la campagne il a dit bien
entendu loin de moi l'idée de vouloir
interrompre l'accueil des réfugiés
Ukrainiens alors tiens d'ailleurs c'est
marrant je vous redonne la parole tout
de suite à l'une à l'autre mais on va
écouter Robert fizzo parce que juste
après les résultats législatives on voit
qu'il est prudent il ne redit pas ce
qu'il avait dit dans sa campagne sur les
livraisons d'armes à l'Ukraine écoute-le
nous pensons que l'Ukraine est une
immense tragédie pour tous et si mon
parti forme le cabinet il est ou non le
Premier ministre nous ferons de notre
mieux même au sein de l'Union européenne
pour que des pourparler de paix soit
engagés dès que possible
nous sommes prêts à fournir une aide
humanitaire et à contribuer à la
reconstruction du pays mais vous
connaissez notre opinion sur l'armement
de l'Ukraine
et vous connaissez notre vidéo sur la
redit pas évidemment au soir de des
résultats de cette élection
législative Christine
parce qu'effectivement la Slovaquie fait
partie de l'OTAN est-ce qu'elle a la
possibilité de mettre un veto à une
entrée éventuelle même si tout ça est
très hypothétique de l'Ukraine dans
l'OTAN en quoi voilà ce
partenaire turbulent peut compliquer le
travail de l'OTAN alors là encore et je
partage la vie qui a été donnée oui il a
un pourcentage important pour autant à
ce qu'il sera en capacité
de mener la politique qui lui plaît à
lui et à lui seul on on en est pas là et
c'est valable pour tous les niveaux
est-ce que par contre on peut avoir des
pertes temps des signaux qui seront
recapitalisés d'un point de vue
informationnel par l'extérieur voir en
interne de la Russie et ça ça pourrait
être assez important c'est à dire au
niveau domestique en disant envoyer bien
que l'Union européenne est divisée que
etc donc ça ça pourrait être repris au
niveau domestique
de tout bois pour montrer justement
cette division etc néanmoins on voit la
prudence qu'il applique ce qui lui
permet aussi de pouvoir rester dans une
espèce de tentative de négociation
qu'il aurait avec notamment les membres
avec lesquels il devra faire alliance de
toute manière selon la position qu'il
aura là encore on a beaucoup de si on
est quand même beaucoup dans
l'hypothétiques
les négociations qu'ils pourraient avoir
avec les contreparties et encore une
fois
tout frontalier qu'il soit
l'OTAN est quand même une machine qui a
de nombreux avantages et en sortir de
manière brutale pourraient créer à moins
pour le moins des dissensions au niveau
national encore une fois on est sur un
pays qui est frontalier il y a une
véritable crainte de sert de plusieurs
populations frontières de la Russie à
l'heure actuelle de ce qui pourrait
arriver et l'idée d'avoir une protection
au tanyenne et loin d'être loin d'être
neutre donc encore une fois 23% qui se
sont exprimés ceux qui ne se sont pas
exprimés ou qui peuvent dans des cas de
tension avoir une position plus modérée
sur certains
ne veut pas du tout sortir de l'OTAN à
aucun moment il a dit qu'il voulait
sortir de l'OTAN c'est même au-delà
au-delà d'une question d'intérêt et
c'est fondamentalement il fait partie de
ces dirigeants européens et ça inclut
Orban et ça inclut les dirigeants
polonais pour lequel finalement l'Europe
devrait être sous protection américaine
point ça ne lui pose aucun problème s'il
a un problème c'est plutôt avec
l'autonomie stratégique version Emmanuel
Macron ça ça ne l'intéresse pas du tout
tout par contre je crois qu'il y a deux
choses d'abord le véto Orban l'a fait
Orban a mis son veto à l'entrée de la
Suède dans l'OTAN et donc il a allié sa
voix à celle d'Erdogan Erdogan on sait
pourquoi c'est les relations avec les
actinistes Kurdes qu'il y a à Stockholm
mais Orban c'était clairement pour en
gros se faire se montrer au salt le
temps comme un dissident possible donc
fidso pourrait jouer ce jeu là
s'il vient au gouvernement il a quand
même une grande difficulté c'est que son
pays ne compte que 5 millions
d'habitants et qu'il est complètement
symbiose avec son ancien pays frères qui
est la République tchèque puisque la
Slovaquie et le résultat d'un divorce de
la Tchécoslovaquie et les flux de
frontaliers entre les deux pays sont
énormes surtout d'ailleurs dans le sens
des Slovaques vers la République tchèque
et donc ça c'est pas du tout la même
équation que l'équation disons
neutraliste hongroise il y a il y a un
nationalisme hongrois traditionnellement
porté vers la Russie le nationalisme
slovaque il a longtemps été contre la
République tchèque et aujourd'hui vous
avez beaucoup de Slovaques qui
regrettent ou qui ne vivent pas cette
indépendance là nécessairement de
manière je dirais toute toujours
heureuse donc c'est c'est compliqué pour
lui ça sera pas simple ce qui est
inquiétant encore une fois moi c'est ça
qui me préoccupe c'est au sein de
l'Union européenne parce que
Ursula wanderleyen la présence de la
commission elle veut être reconduite en
tout cas il semble elle le fasse déjà
campagne on va avoir des élections
européennes dominées par les
souverainistes et là le discours d'un
fixo le discours des Polonais le
discours de Orban peut avoir un écho
bien au-delà de leurs frontières et donc
s'ils sont très représentés au Parlement
une conséquence sur la composition de la
future Commission européenne
effectivement tiens on peut parler un
peu de de des politiques français sur
qui qui s'était affiché prorus et qui
est très profils bas aujourd'hui il y a
quasiment pas ou aucun responsable
politique français qui affiche
effectivement une forme évidemment de
soutien ni de proximité avec Vladimir
Poutine pendant cette campagne ils sont
extrêmement prudents là-dessus
évidemment premier lieu pour Jean-Marie
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen
il est pas question de remettre une
pièce sur un sujet sur lequel ils ont
été particulièrement dansé ces derniers
mois et de revoir revenir finalement des
polémiques qu'ils ont cherché à battre
en brèche depuis le début de cette
guerre en Ukraine regardez d'ailleurs la
semaine prochaine la semaine dernière le
rassemblement national
cette empressé de faire savoir qu'ils
avaient ça y est remboursé entièrement
leur prêt à une banque russe un prêt
d'un peu plus de 6 millions d'euros
évidemment l'objectif c'est d'enlever
une épine du pied notamment de Jordan
Bardella pour sa campagne leur des
élections européennes le RN qui avait
été aussi accusé récemment dans un
rapport parlementaire qu'ils avaient
pourtant demandé au début dans lequel
ils se sont fait politiquement en tout
cas un petit peu piégé par leurs
opposants le RN qui a été accusé d'avoir
été je cite une courroie de transmission
de Moscou notamment au moment de
l'annexion de la Crimée en 2014 un
rapport qui avait été évidemment dénoncé
immédiatement par Marine Le Pen qu'elle
a jugé malhonnête je cite et politisé
finalement les deux qui apparaissent le
plus modéré dans le soutien à l'Ukraine
le mieux qu'on puisse dire c'est des
responsables politiques c'est pas leur
faire injure de second comme par exemple
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan ou Florian
Philippot le responsable ou l'ex
responsable politique de premier plan
qui a peut-être le plus étonné par sa
prise de position ces dernières semaines
vous savez qui c'est c'est Nicolas
Sarkozy parce que Nicolas Sarkozy c'est
propos on en parlait il y a un instant
d'ailleurs été repris à Moscou notamment
par mitry-méda l'ancien président et
premier ministre russe qui était
empressé de reprendre ce qu'avait dit
l'ancien chef d'État français puisqu'il
a estimé Nicolas Sarkozy qu'on pouvait
tout à fait discuter avec Vladimir
Poutine qu'il avait appelé à une sorte
de référendum finalement sur la partie
de la Crimée mais pour entériner
finalement l'état de fait actuel et
l'appartenance et donc l'annexion à la
Russie le fait que d'après lui est bien
l'Ukraine doit absolument rester neutre
et donc il n'est pas question
effectivement de l'intégrer notamment à
l'OTAN dans les années à venir Christine
est-ce que c'est ça ce qui est en train
de se jouer finalement
déclaration Nicolas Sarkozy qui ont pu
choquer mais c'est la porte des
négociations qui s'ouvrent de plus en
plus grand dans en tout cas dans
l'esprit d'une partie des opinions
publiques qui sont effectivement lassés
de la crise économique comme on l'a dit
il y a eu un pari qui a été fait sur le
temps long et sur la difficulté à
maintenir non seulement les formes et le
soutien sur le tendon ça a de Paris qui
a été fait depuis le début par la Russie
en comptant sur l'impact économique la
crise la fatigue la lassitude et puis
simplement le fait que on s'habitue à
avoir aux informations des bombardements
etc et que ça devient quelque part un
quotidien une nouvelle communauté avec
laquelle on prend un petit peu de
distance il y a aussi tout le discours
qui pardon nous interromptes qui a eu
sur la contre-offensive aussi alors
peut-être que nous journalistes les
médias on peut porter une part de
responsabilité je ne sais pas mais cette
espèce de de
contre-offensive qui devait moi j'ai
souvent entendu sur le plateau c'est un
fusil à un coup il faut que ça marche il
faut que ça aille vite etc puis là
finalement on se rend compte que ça dure
que c'est très difficile de gagner du
terrain et donc ça alimente cette
lassitude et pourtant c'était quelque
chose de d'extrêmement prévisible on a
passé un hiver complet avec une Russie
qui a enfin qui a sédimenté ses
positions qui les a renforcé donc on a
parlé très longtemps des modes de
renforcement des différentes lignes
qui a quand même appris que c'est quand
même structuré et vous avez une crème
qui essayait de trouver dans une
position inversée par rapport à d'autres
endroits c'est à dire à devoir reprendre
des territoires qui ont eu le temps
d'être d'être renforcé et évidemment
c'est extrêmement complexe plus le
besoin que vous allez que vous avez en
matériel donc tout cela était
relativement prévisible même si on a
toujours envie de croire à une percée
extrêmement rapide et à une avancée en
gain de territoire il était prévisible
que ça serait une contre-offensive
longue coûteuse et qui est s’inscrirait
dans le temps et ça a été d'ailleurs
à plusieurs reprises en disant voilà il
va il va falloir être en capacité de
maintenir l'effort donc évidemment sans
avoir des paris de temps en disant voilà
vous serez plus à six mois vous serez
plus à un an puisque en règle générale
ce genre de prédiction est quand même
plus aléatoire mais qu'il y aurait une
résistance et qu'on aurait une
complexité
c'était je veux dire c'était pas
forcément une surprise au niveau des
militaires
c'est particulièrement vrai en France ou
en coulisses le gouvernement est
positivement étonné du soutien de
l'opinion publique française quand même
aux mesures et aux condamnations et aux
mesures de rétorsion contre la Russie
parce que évidemment
au moment du déclenchement et des
premières sanctions on était en pleine
campagne présidentielle donc ces
éléments-là étaient particulièrement
regardés par l'équipe évidemment du
président et du candidat Macron et ils
ont continué de le faire depuis ces 18
mois et ce qu'il nous dit c'est qu'ils
sont quand même ils pensaient beaucoup
plus tôt que finalement il y aurait une
chute dans l'opinion du soutien à
l'Ukraine parce que l'inflation parce
que le problème des matières premières
et du coût de l'énergie et il trouve
globalement que finalement jusqu'à leur
ils ont réussi à tenir les deux bouts
vis-à-vis de l'opinion et que ça se
passe moins mal que ce qu'il redoutait
pas le succès escompté alors vous avez
toujours beau jeu de dire oui mais c'est
parce qu'il faut attendre encore un
petit peu et une fin que vous y
arriverons donc vous avez toujours
bouger de le faire mais néanmoins ça a
été un pari qui a été fait et vous avez
si vous voulez au-delà
d'une recherche de soutien frontal
notamment dans les pays de l'Union
européenne pourquoi parce que on a eu ce
front qui a été extrêmement solide et
qui se maintient même si on a des
dissensions avec quelque part des
candidats attendus la Hongrie c'était
pas une surprise sa position par rapport
à l'Ukraine elle a une position au sein
de l'Europe qui est compliquée pour dire
le moins depuis plusieurs années donc là
dessus pas réellement de surprise par
contre ce qui va être ce que l'on va
voir c'est différent narratifs qui sont
moins directement reliés au Kremlin et
au soutien du Kremlin vous le disiez il
y a beaucoup moins de parties qui
pourtant affichaient une certaine
sympathie maintenant on a un mouvement
de rétropédalage et de retrait du
percuteur toutes les placer important
quand on dit OUI nous ne sommes pas nous
mais quels sont les modalités de
négociation de paix et c'est là où on va
voir ce qui sera poussé ou ce qui ne
sera pas poussé et dans quelle mesure et
sur quels arguments on va les appuyer
quelque part ce débat n'aura pas lieu
tant que les soldats Ukrainiens n'auront
pas suffisamment avancé dans les
territoires à reconquérir parce que pour
l'instant ce débat ne se pose pas alors
c'est une question qui se pose aussi aux
États-Unis de déclarations aujourd'hui
d'abord celle du Kremlin qui justement
Paris qui dit la lassitude des opinions
publiques pourraient grandir dans les
prochains mois et la porte-parole de la
Maison Blanche a répondu en disant que
Vladimir Poutine se trompe s'il pense
qu'il va tenir plus longtemps que nous
on se tourne vers la question américaine
avec Steve Jourdain qui va nous
rejoindre tout de suite cette question
les États-Unis vont-ils lâcher l'Ukraine
rebonsoir cible le sujet enflamme le
Congrès actuellement oui on n'est pas
passé loin d'un shot down ce week-end
vous savez c'est cette fermeture de
l'administration fédérale à cause et
bien dans différents d'un désaccord au
Parlement sur la question du budget
chaque année les élus discutent des
fonds qui sont attribués au service
fédéraux et s'ils ne s'entendent pas
avant une date limite et bien le le
gouvernement américain est à court
d'argent et les services fédéraux
doivent tout simplement fermer trois
heures avant la date limite ce samedi le
blocage a finalement été évité Joe Biden
dans un tweet qu'on va voir c'est
félicité du compromis qui a été trouvé
il donne 45 jours supplémentaires pour
élaborer un budget de long terme un
accord a été trouvé mais à quel prix
peut-être au prix de l'Ukraine à
l'avenir nous le dira en tout cas
formellement au moment où l'on se parle
les États-Unis n'aident plus Kiev dans
sa guerre contre Moscou la loi adopter
samedi exclu en effet une nouvelle
enveloppe d'aide de près de 23 milliards
d'euros qui étaient pourtant souhaité
par les élus démocrates si c'était des
passer à la trappe Thomas c'est qu'une
minorité pro Donald Trump dit stop elle
ne veut plus que les impôts des
Américains aillent en soutient à la
guerre en Ukraine le speaker républicain
de la Chambre des représentants ne lui
pas de cet avis mais il doit bien
composer avec la minorité trumpy il y a
quelques jours il a tenté de faire une
synthèse de la position des républicains
écouter le
je comprends nos responsabilités mais je
vais faire passer l'Amérique en premier
si à un moment donné nous devons
rediscuter de l'aide à l'Ukraine nous le
ferons mais je pense que
l'administration doit donner sa propre
définition de la victoire et je lui
demande de venir en parler avec nos élus
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y aura
plus d'aide américaines à l'Ukraine non
d'ailleurs Joe Biden a immédiatement
tenu à rassurer les Ukrainiens écouter
c'était samedi juste après l'annonce du
compromis obtenu sur le budget
nous n'abandonnerons pas l'Ukraine
la grande majorité des deux parties les
démocrates et les républicains du Sénat
et de la chambre
soutient l'aide apporta l'Ukraine dans
le cadre de l'agression brutale dont
elle a été victime de la part de la
Russie
une nouvelle enveloppe pourrait très
bientôt être débloquée peut-être dans
les prochaines semaines un seul chiffre
Thomas pour terminer depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine les Américains on
va prouver plus de 100 milliards d'euros
pour soutenir les Ukrainiens dans leur
conflits contre les Russes merci
beaucoup Steve journal Richard Verly je
me tourne vers vous même si cette
enveloppe de 22,7 milliards de dollars
et finalement voter à louer ça pourrait
être la dernière est-ce que est-ce que
vous iriez justement parce que campagne
électorale qui qui bat son plein etc non
et aujourd'hui le débat pour les
Ukrainiens il n'est pas tellement sur
cette enveloppe il est sur une catégorie
d'armes bien précise qui sont les
missiles à longue portée et là c'est
intéressant de voir que Biden on a parlé
les a quasiment promis et finalement n'a
pas confirmé autrement dit la Maison
Blanche est réticente à offrir à donner
à l'Ukraine les seuls moyens qui lui
permettrait on l'a vu avec les frappes
en Crimée de ces derniers temps qui lui
permettrait d'obliger les Russes à
redistribuer leur troupes le long du
front les redistribuer pour protéger par
exemple la Crimée et donc à pouvoir
accroître leur percée et ça c'est très
significatif c'est à dire que
ne livre pas ce type de missile il y a
aussi la même dilemme en Allemagne avec
les missiles Taurus la France pour sa
part à livrer des missiles tout ça c'est
la même gamme de missiles longue portée
c'est de ça aujourd'hui quand vous
parlez aux Ukrainiens il vous disent
pour l'instant notre priorité c'est ça
dans les semaines qui viennent donc là
quand même il y a un feu orange à la
Maison Blanche mais qui est peut-être
moins budgétaire que directement
militaire oui Christine du règlement
parlé tout à l'heure de des calendriers
politiques des des différents états là
on est sur la question américaine mais
on a évoqué aussi le vaincan les
élections européennes c'est pour le mois
de juin voilà je veux pas à chaque fois
être celui qui dit ça qui plaide le pire
mais
dans un contexte comme celui-là est-ce
que ça peut inciter certains des pays
qui soulignaient soutiennent le plus
l'Ukraine à mettre le pied sur le frein
moi je pense pas mais
c'est l'avenir qu'il dira c'est la
situation des États-Unis d'Amérique
n'est pas exactement la même que celle
des Européens vis-à-vis de ce conflit
parce que vous en parliez tout à l'heure
à propos de la surprise qu'il y a dans
les cercles de pouvoir français que le
soutien à l'Ukraine dans la société
française soit toujours fort et encore
une fois il est fort dans il est il est
toujours fort ou très fort dans 22 pays
sur 27 voilà parce que
ce qu'on peut enfin la manière dont on
peut expliquer cela c'est que entre la
Russie et l'Europe il y a d'une part une
menace on va dire
géographique et territoriale ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour les Américains et
d'autre part il y a vraiment deux
modèles de société qui s'opposent c'est
à dire que
c'est pas juste une histoire de tiens
est-ce qu'on pense que c'est légitime
pour les Russes de reconquérir entre
guillemets ou de considérer que tel
morceau de territoire qui aujourd'hui
est en Ukraine devrait appartenir à la
Russie oui non c'est ce dont on parlait
tout à l'heure les libertés
fondamentales les droits ce qui fait une
démocratie quand bien même c'est à dire
que moi à chaque fois que je suis amené
avec mes étudiants à parler alors la
Crimée elle est russe ou elle est
ukrainienne je dis mais moi je suis pas
spécialiste de l'histoire russe je suis
pas spécial de l'histoire ukrainienne et
le problème dans ce qui nous concerne en
ce moment n'est pas celui-là le problème
c'est que la Russie pour régler un
conflit territorial ou pour faire état
d'une revendication n'a pas été déposée
un dossier devant le tribunal pénal
devant la Cour de justice internationale
de l'ONU qui qui tous les jours toutes
les semaines et tous les mois j'ai rend
des arbitrages en toute un tas de
conflits c'est-à-dire que on a un état
et manifestement un régime politique qui
ne croit pas dans le droit donc non
seulement dans l'État de droit pour
gouverner sa propre société mais qui ne
croient pas dans le fait que pour régler
des différents ou des problèmes le mieux
c'est de s'asseoir autour d'une table et
d'essayer de trouver une solution par la
négociation par le compromis par le
droit c'est pour ça que tous les
populistes comme fit chaud qui disent
mais moi je suis pour la paix je ne
demande qu'à ce qu'on s'assoit tous
ensemble autour d'une table soit il est
très très naïf soit il en fume les gens
parce que on sait très bien que ce qui
caractérise
avec des débats autour de du shutdown
qui a été évité de justesse ça l'est
déjà dans la campagne présidentielle qui
s'amorce à le sera encore plus après
vous dans les prochains mois
de toute façon on l'aura minimum en
toile de fond ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir que on a la transposition
sur des problématiques nationales de la
situation à l'international quand vous
avez des questions qui se posent c'est
quels sont les arbitrages qu'on va
devoir faire comment est-ce que la
population doit avoir voilà vous avez
cette transposition là cela dit encore
une fois jusque là le pari qui a été
fait par l'usure et par la division a
pas tenu au niveau de l'Union européenne
alors par contre que l'on puisse avoir
oui mais au niveau américain au niveau
américain avec un Donald Trump qui va
être selon toute vraisemblance le
candidat public
l'avenir l'avenir le dira mais là encore
ça ne dépend pas que même d'une seule
faction ou d'un seul homme on est sur
des équilibres qui sont qui sont plus
complexes que ça qui se lise à plusieurs
niveaux donc
[Musique]
on verra ce qui on verra ce qu'il lance
ce qu'il en sera à ce moment-là
du fait que Donald Trump on connaissait
lien ou en tout cas une certaine
empathie qu'il pourrait avoir pour
Vladimir Poutine le problème c'est que
est-ce que Joe Biden à son âge peut être
un chef de guerre posez-vous la question
si vous étiez américain il y a une
guerre en Ukraine et Joe Biden doit être
le chef de guerre et c'est là-dessus que
Trump va taper il ne va pas taper sur
l'Ukraine et sur Zelinski il va taper
sur joga Joe Biden comme étant en
capacité d'être chef de guerre et ça
malheureusement il faut constater que ça
peut marcher merci beaucoup merci à tous
je rappelle le titre de votre livre
sylvain-canne l'histoire de la
construction de l'Europe depuis 1945
lieux publiés au presse universitaire de
France et Richard Berli ont voulu
évidemment dans le média Suisse Blic à
très bientôt Guillaume à bientôt sur ce
plateau notez que demain l'invité de la
matinale de Public Sénat ce sera Franck
Papazian qu'au président du Conseil de
coordination des organisations ations
arméniennes de France belle soirée à
toutes et à tous
[Musique]